he's actually one of the
real early i guess progenitors of the
data community dc
uh he's one of the people he saw what
was going on new york and he said you
know what dc can use that he helped
build an amazing community in dc
which we are very proud to partner with
to do this conference they are you know
a bunch of really good people
and we would like to give a big
warm welcome to mark
weissman as he comes up one of the
leaders of dc community
to give us his next talk please welcome
mark
stand up show us your shirt yeah oh yeah
hey
ah there we go yep we're trying
and we even both have the same hoodie on
too my hoodie's on the floor over there
all right have a good talk
thanks so my talk today is
about uh a bunch of collaborative work
that
i've been a part of over the last year
and i'm really really excited to talk
about this this is
this is a joint effort joint work
between
an academic government and industry
collaboration so
several folks are involved in this uh
first of course is the
u.s forest service which is part of the
usda department of agriculture
the second kind of and they're all
related but the second part is uh
florida a m university uh and ascent and
caesar which is the center for spatial
ecology and restoration
and of course microsoft so they're my
customer uh the us4 service is my
customer
as you know i work for microsoft i'll
get that in a second but uh this is
basically a joint effort between
famu for amu the created the center
which is a joint effort between the
academic and
government um and when i was gonna give
the talk i
i told jared i said i can talk about
this topic about using lighter images
for forest management
but i need to ask permission because i
you know the the work really is
is i am part involved in this but the
work is really not my work is really
the work of uh the caesar folks whom
i'll acknowledge in a second and
they gave me permission to talk about
this so i'm really excited thank you
again
uh and again i'm really excited so a big
shout out to caesar at famu so the
center for spatial and ecological
research to jason drake to paul medley
to joe st peter he's probably online
listening to the conference on pedro
uh and jordan vernon so uh i've been
working with this team for the last year
and uh they're doing some really really
cool work um a lot of it in our this is
this is essentially what i'm going to
talk about
so i'm going to talk about just give you
a quick intro to lidar
so i didn't know much about lidar before
before
working with these folks i learned a
little bit more in preparation for this
talk
i'm going to tell you i'm going to show
you ultimately i'm just going to show
you what they're doing and really
really cool stuff how they're using
these lighter images for
for really um interesting analysis and
for forest management conservation
preservation and
all these sorts of other things uh i'm
gonna talk
briefly about the lidar package which is
what
uh what they're using to process these
lidar images and
then i'm also gonna touch on a little
bit on how we took a manual workflow
that they had
uh moved it to the cloud and accelerated
that as well
so uh oh wait
oh and i'm gonna show you some cool so
i'm gonna show you some cool pictures as
well
uh so a little bit about me um for those
that know me
you know that i've been as jared said
i've been part of the the art community
and the science community here in the dc
area for a long time
uh started data community dc ran the
meetups um not as involved as
today i still love being a part of the
conference and i wish like i said to be
in person because i really really love
this community i work for microsoft i'm
part of the microsoft federal team i
work with federal customers
helping them migrate their work into the
cloud my specialty
is in data science machine learning
artificial intelligence
uh r and python of course all the open
source but really you know helping our
customers move
use our platform to do their work you
know that in our fanatic right otherwise
i would probably wouldn't be here
so um the what i'm going to talk about
today again
the work itself is caesar's work uh
opinions are
mine mine alone not necessarily
representative of anyone that i'm
affiliated with
the other thing i wanted to say is for
those that actually don't know another
fun fact is
i actually didn't when i started running
the meetup group 10 years ago i didn't
know
r and today quite earlier today actually
i saw a
tweet in the i saw a thread in twitter
about people
talking about why they had to learn r or
what was the first reason so for me it
was gg plot you know just really
that was like the first thing i actually
learned but really the motivation was
when i started running the meetup i was
really interested in r in the community
but watching other people do really cool
work with r like really motivated me to
learn it as well so that was 10 years
ago of course a lot has happened
in between okay so
what is lidar
lidar is similar to sonar and radar we
all know these terms
right basically it's a sense that
there's a signal that gets emitted
gets received and it gets processed so
you know we know sonar
uh right you know the like the bleeps
and the clips
spaceballs reference here uh or or fun
for whatever but
like you know uses sound waves um and
then radar of course uses radio waves
right emits the wave it receives it back
and it does the processing you kind of
get a sense to what's out there
well guess what later uses anyone care
to guess
actually i'm not watching the chat but
let me see
uh stage anyone care to guess what
lighter uses
oh sorry drum roll
laser
yes i'm being a total goofball i know no
but right so lidar uses
lighter uses um yeah so it's light light
basically laser which is a form of light
right so lidar
it's lighter means light detection and
ranging so
basically what lidar has many
applications there's a lot of it out
there
but in the context of what i'm going to
talk about today essentially is about
collecting uh
aerial lidar images uh from
lighter units that are flown on planes
so these are planes or drones
that fly over areas so there's the ray
of light is sweeping left and right
right and it's you know it's bouncing
the light off and collecting data and so
on and so forth so forth so that that's
what lidar is and that is the source of
the data that
that is that i'm going to show you today
so the lidar uses electromagnetic
spectrum it uses the green light
uh or the near infrared and the reason
why is because those are the ones that
seem to reflect
the best from vegetation and what you
usually see out in the field right
at least lighter now lighter is also
used for example in self-driving cars
and a lot of a lot of new technology
right and um
but and it's the same principles just
that's mounted on a different thing it
could be mounted on your car
i actually think that a lot of uh the
cars that have a lot of the
the safety things or the self-breaking i
don't know what technology they use but
i'm pretty sure that
a lot of self-driving cars use lidar uh
probably some of the commercial cars
like the subarus that have the two
lenses it's probably using lighter i'm
not
i'm not sure but anyway um but the point
is that you can uh
you can either emit later from the
ground emitted from satellites
or from planes which is probably the
most the most common
thing so what makes up the lidar
lighter device or the lidar system uh
it's the lidar unit itself which is
attached to the bottom of an aircraft or
a drone
right and it's it's as though the plane
is flying it's
it's scanning it's emitting a array of
light that's going left to right
there's a gps right which pinpoints the
position it helps
uh also understand not just the xy but
also the elevation
uh using gps locations and then third it
also uses the
inertial measurement unit because what
happens is
you know as the plane flies it moves
also the light
because it's a ray that's going back and
forth left to right there is an
angle so you need to know the angle of
the plane you need to know the angle of
the
of the light beam so there's a lot of
not just the data that gets collected
back
but there's also a lot of metadata that
gets processed to create all of these
images
and what happens right when the laser
beam is going left to right
it's hitting on objects but in the case
of vegetation and probably
other objects as well it penetrates so
you actually get many responses at the
same
point so when i talk about the images in
a little bit
i'm going to talk about the response or
multiple readings
and what you get looks something like
this so when you
get all that data and it's
post-processed so there's also a
computer and software that takes all the
stuff and creates these
images what you get out of later system
is what's called a point cloud
so it's essentially a set of 3d images
that is multi it's basically essentially
a multi-dimensional array
where there's many different dimensions
for of course the
the response the xy location the
measurements like all of these things
get packaged into this
file type called point cloud which is of
the type
uh the the data file itself is of a type
last
so that's that's the i don't know what
it actually last stands for i don't
think it starts for anything but
um it's a last file so it's a point
cloud
and it's a last file it's a standard uh
it's uh
done by the american society uh
programmatory and remote sensing
there's a github link over here this is
just a part of the specification this
was updated uh fairly recently
okay so that's really what ladar is and
those are the images
that that the folks at caesar and other
agencies are working with right
lighter is actually it is readily
available um so
from what i understand is there is
actually a lot of lidar
data out there and a lot in government
state local
governments um spend a lot of money
collecting this data
um for other purposes so
and just to give you an idea right and
and these statistics were
provided to me so in in 2019 and 2020
the state of florida
spent about was it 23 million dollars
for about 38 000 square miles so roughly
about 600
per square mile to collect there's
another one here another statistic which
is about 200 dollars per square mile but
they actually the point is that they fly
these drones or aircraft and they
collect the lighter data for other
reasons usually for the purposes of what
creating work called digital elevation
models
um but the ancillary use is what i'm
actually going to talk about
right so the folks um so the the folks
at caesar and other teams have figured
out have
they they're using this data that has
been collected for other purposes for
the purposes of
forest management
um like i said they are they're
leveraging this data that has been
already collected
uh and get additional learnings about
this and one of the things that they're
using is to to
calculate structural characteristics of
forests things like forest height and
canopy cover
which when you get that it's a strong
correlation to
things about a forest about you know the
amount of timber
the biomass which is the amount of
organic material that's there
the habitat quality so they can use
these measurements
and also layer with other data i'm not
going to talk about it but you can also
layer this with satellite data and these
other things but ultimately it's about
it's about understanding the metrics
about making decisions
and what they're doing with this which
is really cool right is they're building
you know they're building hydrologic
hydrology models
they're building forest inventory so
they're trying to understand you know
the evolution of forests over time
uh they're they're trying to make
strategic decisions especially as it
relates to uh event response natural
event
response so using the data in pre and
post hurricane image uh
forest analysis for example uh identify
areas in the forest
for maintenance and restoration and or
preservation so there's just
there's a lot of different things that
you can do with the product of these um
of these data sets and ultimately what
happens right
when you take these data sets and you
leverage open source technologies and
tools like r
for example uh machine learning and the
cloud
it gives you better accuracy for a much
less cost than uh
than doing this manually you know and
has before these lighter data
people have to go into the field and
collect this data manually so you can
imagine you can't really scale
a person to cover a broad area you know
whereas in flights you can cover a
pretty broad area in a short amount of
time so
of course there are traders but
ultimately the long-term idea is to
really leverage this data
fully integrate this into many processes
and
share this data across agencies etc to
really
build a full-blown end-to-end process
so this is how you don't collect lighter
data
one second i'm sorry joe
so this was last year and i think it was
october
i was down at the apalachicola national
forest so the folks that sees our
family they're based out of tallahassee
and we went out into the field they were
doing some testing of these fixed
wing drones uh testing multiple vendors
this one
i believe is sensefly um it's a fixed
one grown
that one actually did not have a lidar
sensor in it but
i just thought it was fun to show anyway
but
they actually do there is a lighter
sensor it's not as sophisticated
uh the images i'm going to show you come
from different devices but uh
nonetheless i
wanted to show you that okay
so i told you i was gonna show you some
cool pictures all right so
when you we're going to look at some
what are called point cloud uh
files so this is what a point cloud
looks like so
this is um this is an image that's
coming from
the gator i system and the gateway
system is a really high definition high
density
lidar system it gives you about 5 000
points per square meter which is
pretty dense uh whereas other systems
can give you anywhere from four to eight
meter
uh points per square meter i mean it
varies but this one is really ultra
ultra high definition
of course the higher the definition the
bigger the file
um you know the higher the definition
the shorter the
or the smaller the area you can cover on
a given point for the detail
so there's different levels right of
lighter there's sort of like lower
low resolution bigger area higher
resolution lower areas sort of
everywhere in between so
this is an example um i believe that
this is part of the apple this is
western appalachia cola
uh and these images were taking right
after hurricane
michael in 2018 if i'm not mistaken so
i'm gonna you can't really see it here
these are just a couple of different
examples so this is actually what
happens right you see all these
different points
and and that's all the data that gets
collected as the beam gets thrown down
you get a response and all this data
gets processed this is what's
called the point cloud and this is what
is used sort of those raw data for
downstream analysis for building other
other products that they're using for
doing other kinds of analytics
uh this one in this image in particular
you can sort of see a little bit of
of an area in in the blue which is the
area closer to the ground that's
uh that's less populated that's kind of
an area where trees fell
so this is uh this was a flight path
right after the
hurricane michael which was in the
panhandle area
uh and this flight path was near the
area where the hurricane went through so
just to give you an idea uh so these are
a point cloud files
um this is a tiff file so what ends up
happening is once you collect all this
data
it you you create or there's there's
multiple levels here but you can extract
a lot of this uh a lot of layers from
the point cloud
and also create a little bit uh create
tiff files which are used
downstream but this these are
multi-layer tiffs so if you open a
multi-layer tiff in like a typical
tiff viewer like on your computer
whatever image you have
because it's multiple layer you can't
you're not seeing anything so here we're
actually seeing is the flight path
um and if i come here and i take my
mouse and i kind of hover it
over this uh i guess you can see it but
essentially what you see here is the
the whole flight path and and you see us
a wide strip because that's the laser
beam that's
panning left to right as the as the
plane is moving so this is sort of that
circular flight
and the images that we saw that i showed
you earlier were actually a part of this
flight but this is
this is looking at the entirety of the
image projected onto a single plane
without any color because it's just
a bunch of data projected in a single
plane
well how do these get used um so they
work on creating what are called raster
products from these lighter
point clouds and when we say raster it
basically means a grid so
uh it's it rastering since it's
two-dimensional but it's partitioned by
grid
and those are the kinds of images that
are really used downstream to produce
further analysis so i'm going to show
you some of the inputs and outputs
that are created um so for example so
this is a subset of that bigger flight
that i just
showed you so this is just zeroing on a
really small area just for the sake of
uh illustration but just also because
also the image sizes are
much smaller and i can actually show you
what
a bunch of these things look like so
this is this is an aerial photo this
just comes from satellite
from the esri platform which is a gis
platform
so when you overlay the 2d point this is
just the raw
2d point glide but it's overlaid on the
on the aerial image just so you get a
sense as to where things are
this is the 3d point cloud of that same
area of course it's not look it's
it's see it's the the point of view is
not from directly from the top it's sort
of coming from the side but ultimately
again these are point clouds but then we
start getting into what are called the
raster so this is where you're actually
taking
the from from the point cloud data you
can filter
different bands and look at specific
parts of this so this is looking at the
canopy
um at the canopy height right it's kind
of like tree height
or not so a blue is more open canopy
uh red is denser canopy and if we go
back to the satellite right you see that
blue right there's in this area over
here or kind of towards the bottom
middle there's less trees
and you see that it's blue because it's
open um the next one
sorry that's three roads so that's
canopy height this is canopy cover
so this is the height of the trees this
is actually the the cover of the trees
and you can see
that the reds are more more trees more
leaves blue is less leaves
and so on and so forth right this is one
version of it
um this is so this is canopy cover
this is another canopy cover here uh
actually this is shrubs
this is a shrub cover sorry i mislabeled
the slide and
blue is no or low shrub cover orange or
red means it's dense
and then here we're actually combining
all of these these
different layers into a single image so
the green is canopy cover
the uh the blue is the shrub density so
shrubs meaning lower trees
right uh and the red is the canopy
canopy height so it's really really tall
tree is kind of where the things is so
here you actually get a
multi-dimensional
um layer like in in a grid right this is
a two-dimensional projection
in a grid because every grid uh is this
is resolution of one meter i believe one
square meter
so there are metrics or calculations
that are done per
grid per grid grid cell to produce these
images right
this basically essentially is a heat map
for a lack of a better term
um this is a sweep right this is kind of
a
a sliced view of of this of the
longitudinal or lateral sweep
so it's the same image we're just
looking at it from here so you can see
that you can do
um again i'm not an ecologist or an
arborist or
something like that but they're actually
doing a lot of uh and gleaning a lot of
information actual information from
these images
they're using the lidar package for that
uh so i'm just gonna show you a couple
of functions basically what you do with
the lidar so lidar
is a package uh it's it's it's an active
development
uh it seems to be the best tool out
there for doing this kind of stuff
in r particularly but also um they tried
a bunch of different workflows and it
seemed that this was the best so
you load the library the library does
use raster it uses sp
uh you need gdal as well for certain
things not for what i'm showing you here
today but
the last file can be either part of a
catalog or it can be a single file so
you can read in the catalog which is
just really in the metadata remember
each of these files is really big so um
that the big file the gator i file
that's about
the one i show you that was about eight
gigabytes um the other one the subset
was
less than about 500 megs these are
pretty large files
so when you can do a catalog in a
catalog as basically a grid of images
or a single image um but again so here
we're reading in a single image
you can see that that image covers about
four
point zero square kilometers there's 274
million data points in that particular
last file
but then we can subset that you can clip
it give it coordinates and clip it and
subset it and here we're looking at a
smaller
file which is about 36
hundred 36 000 square meters much less 7
million data points as opposed to 100
and something something so
you can plot this directly with methods
in r and get some of the images that i
showed you
and then you can post process this but
ultimately um
what they've done is they've created a
set of standard metrics or not entire
custom metrics
that uh basically reads in the file and
produces all these sorts of metrics per
layer
uh produces a list output and that's
what they use to produce
the downstream analysis so i need to
wrap up i know so we
um we actually migrated this workflow
from local
workstations that were using data and
hard drives uh you know
eight core machines with not a lot of
memory into the cloud so
using larger scale machines with more
cpus more memory the data is already in
the cloud so the speeds
so we've really accelerated the the
process for being able to process uh
you know mult many many terabytes of
data uh
in the cloud and that's one of the
things that i've actually been working
on with um
with the team so you know just to kind
of wrap up
this really has a really huge impact
because they're
working on the scalable repeatable
methodology that can be applied
again over many national forests used by
other government agencies and also
build a workflow that folks that don't
have maybe the skills or the computer
resources are going to be able to use
and replicate
uh like i said this is the best workflow
that they've been able to find in terms
of
um of trying a bunch of different things
and the raster images those 2d images
are actually used as inputs for machine
learning models
that can be a whole talk on its own and
like i said it really
reduces the time to assess natural
disaster impact
thank you uh this talk was actually made
with sharingan
i've been using sharing again a lot for
the last year in building slides for
class i mean as you know i teach at
georgetown i forgot to mention that
i really like sharingan this is uh this
was built in sharing in an art american
so
thanks a lot guys mark mentioned we were
twinning because we're both wearing
dcr shirts the blue dcr shirts but you
notice he was wearing a hoodie
it was the nyr hoodie so we were
twinning in
more than one way and mark was supposed
to introduce me
but he didn't show up so he didn't get
his chance and he said for his fun fact
that i should just take a jab at him
so of course i had to be nice but mark's
an awesome guy we love each other he's
doing really great stuff for the
community
so our next speaker is